les scientifiques le disent depuis des
années la planète vit une crise
environnementale sans précédent les
changements climatiques et les pressions
exercées par l'homme ont mis à mal la
biodiversité partout sur la terre mais
qu'en est il exactement chez nous des
chercheurs tentent de mesurer la
biodiversité pour qu'on puisse mieux la
protéger
[Musique]
étrange ballet au parc national de la
jacques-cartier
une équipe du ministère des forêts de la
faune et des parcs du québec est à
l'oeuvre
[Musique]
sa mission établir un portrait précis de
la biodiversité de l'ensemble du québec
au moment où les changements climatique
s'accentue
[Musique]
c'est sûr qu'il ya un sentiment
d'urgence de savoir que des espèces qui
disparaissent qu'on les connaît pas dés
jetés oui oui ça bouge rapidement ça
change rapidement il ya des enjeux
majeurs parce qu'il ya plusieurs menaces
de front
[Musique]
l'urgence d'agir face à une crise
environnementale sans précédent est au
coeur de ce projet
en plus des changements climatiques les
milieux naturels se dégradent sous la
pression qu'exercent les humains
[Musique]
les conséquences sont dramatiques
selon une étude récente de l'onu de 38 à
46 % des espèces animales et végétales
de la planète pourraient disparaître
d'ici 2050
je pense que de mettre un baromètre dans
nos écosystèmes pour savoir exactement
qu'est ce qui se passe ce tour gens
parce qu'il ya tellement de choses qu'on
ne mesure pas et qu'on ne sait pas donc
avant qu'elle disparaisse c'est
important de pouvoir acheter de tirs
puis regardez qu'est ce qu'on peut faire
avec ça
cette perte de biodiversité est
préoccupant
nos sociétés dépendent d'une foule de
services essentiels que nous procure des
écosystèmes en santé
comme l'approvisionnement en nourriture
la pollinisation
la purification de l'eau
et la production de médicaments
cette biodiversité la ccc vraiment la
clé de la résilience la clé de de
pouvoir d'avoir une meilleure
adaptabilité dans un contexte de
changement climatique et de
modifications anthropique c'est vraiment
important de la conserver parce que
c'est un peu une garantie pour le futur
[Musique]
comme il n'existait aucun portrait
global de l'état de la biodiversité du
québec le ministère de l'environnement
et celui des forêts de la faune et des
parcs ont mis sur pied le réseau de
suivi de la biodiversité du québec
[Musique]
cet outil permettra d'évaluer l'effet
des changements climatiques sur la
biodiversité
d'identifier les problèmes et de
proposer des mesures de conservation
efficace
nous mêmes on en fait partie et puis je
pense que c'est important que ça fasse
partie prenante de nos vies
c'est des fois ce qu'on connaît pas bien
on s'en préoccupe
[Musique]
plus de 1000 sites de suivi sont prévus
tant au nord qu'au sud du québec les
principaux types de milieux seront
étudiées
l'objectif mieux comprendre les
tendances globales tout en tenant compte
de la diversité régionale
l'ensemble des parcs nationaux du québec
vont aussi être scrutée à la loupe
c'est au parc sanscartier on a pu mettre
en place une cellule complète on va
retrouver un milieu forestier une
tourbière un marais un lac et un cours
d'eau pour chacun de ces types de
milieux là on va avoir des suivi
d'indicateurs différents selon le type
de milieu ou est-ce qu'on straw
[Musique]
on utilise 75 indicateurs pour évaluer
l'état de la biodiversité
donc on va faire la température de l'eau
par shine de terre - graf on va
également suivre le zooplancton
on fait également de l'adn
environnementale et certains paramètres
physicochimiques sur le terrain et en
laboratoire
sur la terre ferme les techniciens et
les biologistes installe des
enregistreurs sonore des caméras et des
pillages
il mesure l'abondance la diversité et
l'air de répartition de la faune et de
la flore
des événements importants comme la date
de reproduction ou celle de la migration
des animaux sont aussi analysées
on va également avoir
des stations
phénologique donc c'est des caméras qui
vont prendre en photo déplaçables de
végétation pour pouvoir suivre
l'évolution de la croissance au cours de
la saison
un bon indicateur est facilement
mesurable et réagir rapidement aux
modifications engendrées par les
changements climatiques
ce qui va être le plus précieux dans nos
indicateurs c'est qu'ils peuvent se
parler donc c'est très inhabituel avoir
des indicateurs qui se parlent les uns
aux autres donc dans ce cas là par
exemple on va avoir la vitesse et des
compositions les insectes on peut avoir
par exemple en est la clé communautés de
poissons les au plancton la
physico-chimie donc toutes ces liens là
qu'on peut faire dans les écosystèmes
vont servir à améliorer les décisions et
à comprendre les répercussions de
certains éléments dans toute la chaîne
trophique on a beaucoup d'indicateurs à
changements rapides donc ça va on n'est
ce pas pour ceux nés de certaines
sonnette d'alarmé au niveau des
changements appréhender
non loin de là toujours dans le parc
national de la jacques-cartier
la société des établissements de plein
air du québec la sépaq déploie une
soixantaine d'appareils d'enregistrement
automatisé pour capter les sons émis par
les oiseaux et les grenouilles
ce qu'on veut savoir c'est comment la
qualité du milieu évolue est ce que
l'écosystème et en santé est-ce que les
espèces qu'on s'attend à trouver dans
les différents écosystèmes sont
présentés abondante et aussi on veut
voir comment ça évolue dans le temps et
puis les grenouilles pour le milieu
aquatique et les oiseaux plus
globalement sont des très bon indicateur
de ce qui se passe non seulement le
calme mais à des échelles plus grande ou
si
les enregistreurs automatisés sont
devenues un véritable atout pour les
biologistes cette nouvelle approche
technologique permet d'avoir une
meilleure couverture du territoire un
plus grand nombre de jours d'inventaire
et donc une meilleure fiabilité des
résultats c'est d'avoir comme une armée
d'observateurs qui peuvent aller
chercher des données partout en même
temps et à toute heure du jour donc ça
c'est un avantage majeur
c'est une bonne façon d'aller chercher
des espèces rares parce que évidemment
en augmentant la durée d'enregistrement
et le nombre de ces tout on est
simultanément on a plus de chance de
détecter les espèces peu communes
par exemple on aimerait bien entendre le
moucherolle à côté olive
l'engoulevent d'amérique
ou encore la grive de bicknell une
espèces qui nichent en altitude dans des
milieux difficiles d'accès
l'oreille de l'homme est encore
nécessaire pour identifier les espèces
mais les chercheurs vont aussi mettre à
profit les dernières avancées dans le
domaine de l'intelligence artificielle
compte tenu de l'immense quantité de
données obtenues
c'est un cas classique d'intelligence
artificielle où finalement on fournit
aux logiciels ce qu'on veut l'identifier
donc une vocalisation de grenouilles ou
d'oiseaux ensuite le logiciel recherche
7 vocalisation le dans l'enregistrement
c'est un outil exceptionnel on est
vraiment contents de tester cet outil la
voir si c'est possible de le déployer à
grande envergure dans le réseau moi je
pense que oui on est vraiment à près d'y
arriver
éventuellement on va être capable de
fournir un fichier de 200 et avoir la
liste d'espèces à la sortie
les informations recueillies par la
sepaq serviront aussi aux grands réseaux
de suivi de la biodiversité du québec
on a été comme en communication et en
coordination dans ce projet là parce
qu'on voulait avoir les mêmes plages
d'enregistrement pour notre inventaire
général d'oiseaux et de grenouilles pour
que les données soient compatibles
tous ces efforts permettront d'intégrer
la biodiversité dans la prise de
décision comme le préconise la
convention sur la diversité biologique
des nations unies
et une mouvance mondiale d'un intérêt
d'être capable de rendre des comptes sur
la biodiversité
en 2022 les résultats des indicateurs
devraient être accessibles à tous
citoyens chercheurs et décideurs grâce à
un portail web d'observation de la
biodiversité
c'est sûr que plus à notre connaissance
by mieux on peut baser nos décisions sur
ses connaissances de cette dynamique
l'autre tout un réseau de personnes qui
veulent finalement meilleure protection
des écosystèmes de façon générale qui
veut promouvoir la biodiversité je
trouve que c'est vraiment un défilé un
projet superbe
[Musique]